biff lève les lives quitter l'europe
voilà le choix exprimé par les
britanniques
c'était le 23 juin 2016 en même temps
depuis que la communauté européenne
existe entre le royaume uni et l'europe
disons que it's complicated en fait dès
les fondements de l'union européenne les
britishs n'était pas très emballé par la
communauté
voilà ce que disait le premier ministre
winston churchill au général de gaulle
en 1944 entre l'europe et le grand large
nous choisirons toujours de grand large
finalement en 1973 le royaume uni
intègre la communauté européenne
depuis comment la population at elle
réagi aux différentes décisions en 1989
des élections européennes avec un taux
de participation de 38 % il ya un an
elle ici et à la manche et diffusant à
côté de leur part en 1991 ils sont les
seuls à refuser l'euro et la suppression
des frontières
nous ne sommes pas prêts pour l'europe
et quand 1999 arrive la monnaie unique
la france l'espagne l'allemagne ont des
économies très différentes
on va attendre qu'il se planter en
ramassera les morceaux à vrai dire à
chaque rendez vous européen selon les
sondages environ la moitié des
britanniques sont opposés au projet leur
profil
ils sont plutôt éloignés des villes
assez âgés et peu diplômé en 2012
l'opinion est sondée sur la question
cruciale de la sortie de l'union
souhaité par 56 % de l'opinion l'europe
en fait ça ne fonctionne pas nous sommes
les seuls à bien nous en sortir bien
faire le contraire des autres sur à peu
près tous les sujets
et ça a toujours été notre façon d'être
avec ça c'était les prémices du
breakbeat soumis au référendum quatre
ans plus tard 51 9% des votants ont
choisi de prendre le match
[Musique]